and now where we are is every week every
customer who gives us below a nine
gets a cop gets some form of contact
interesting a phone call from our
customer experience team an email and
it's a lot it's a ton but every possible
person that we can affect
we connect with and make sure it's a
a better experience than where maybe we
left it with them and then we learn from
it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders this is
about direct to consumer and about
strategy and of course startups and
entrepreneurship
meet mike hollenstein the ceo at ibops
leading the company and direct to retail
and wholesale growth he was appointed to
the ceo role in december of 2017 after
joining the organization in july of 2016
as vice president of direct and
operations
prior to joining ibobs hollenstein was
vice president merchandising for
sportsman's guide as leader of the
product management team he helped
sportsmen's guide deliver over 300
million dollars of annual volume
previously holland stein led the direct
purchase division at gnk services and
from 2000 to 2008 he helped build the
duluth trading co business as vice
president of product development
tell me a little bit about
about ibob and you know who are you guys
yeah
yeah so ibob started uh just about 21
years ago here in minneapolis
by our founder julie allenson and it
really was born out of a need
she was just north of 40 years old and
she was having a harder and harder time
seeing her notes and her books
and she went out to find a cool pair of
reading glasses and
ultimately truly she was working with a
startup and
she was in a you know went out to see
her favorite optician
and he said well you can either spend
ten dollars on a pair of drugstore
readers or cheaters
or i can sell you a pair of 500 or a
thousand dollar really beautiful frames
with sync with some single vision reader
lenses in them and she was from that
moment on it was like oh my goodness
this is the idea i've been looking for
and i went to find a vendor
who literally traveled there
built a small collection and there's a
men's store here in minneapolis who said
yep we'll take them on but we're not
going to pay for them
until we sell them
and they sold out in a few and then just
a real short amount
and um
that was the start of the idea and now
today we're we're in three channels we
still sell through wholesale we sell
through the direct channel which we i'd
love to get into the challenges
associated with that with eyewear with
you and talk a little bit about that
and then we also have our own retail
stores so it's really a lot of things
have happened in between the founding
and today but it's it really is a it's a
wonderful story uh of an entrepreneur
taking a risk and and building a really
awesome thing it sounds really great and
you know walk me through where we are
today in terms of
you know the way that you're thinking
through you know retail e-commerce
direct to consumer online marketing i
mean you have this you know it's if
before it was let's build a great
product put it on shelves and see if
people will buy it right today there's
so many more layers of complexity that
you have to take into account and
strategy and be strategic about and you
have worked with different organizations
and have you know worked as an executive
on different brands and and i'm sure
that that also shaped your strategy here
but but
share with me a little bit about how
you're seeing the world today through
the lenses of ibob
you bet um you know i think it's i've
been ceo here now for four years it's my
first time as a ceo i've led divisions
of companies but never as a ceo
and i will tell you i think the most
important thing that i've done we've
done is really simplify we've simplified
our message we've simplified the
business
and at the end of the day
it's all about us being a direct to
consumer company we're not going to
apologize for that because what is that
what does that do it makes you focus on
the customer and we happen to sell
through other
channels like wholesale and five or ten
years ago there was this concept of
channel conflict well if you're going to
sell through
a big department store
how can you sell yourself how can you
sell direct to the consumer and the
reality of it is a rising tide raises
all those if you do it the right way if
you don't discount and you don't hold
them accountable to things that you're
not holding yourself accountable to
so we start there at the end of the day
we're we're a direct to consumer company
that wants to be where our consumer is
at the time they're ready to buy period
um we also our strategy is very simple
we focus on three objectives products
people and brands
product is our driver we are a product
based company we make bold eyewear
we dare people to to buy eyewear that's
bold and that represents their
personality and there's nothing more
exciting and interesting i didn't
understand this before i started here
then when somebody puts on a pair of
glasses and you see their their
shoulders go a little further back and
they feel good about themselves so we
are a product company
first and foremost
and the product we sell is the frames
the lenses are incredibly really
important but we we're not going to
limit ourselves by the let the lenses we
sell so we've really greatly expanded
our lens options from readers only to
blue light to prescription to
sun all of those things so that's the
product side and then the brand side the
brands evolved a lot and i learned that
duruth trading company when i was there
a great product without stellar branding
is a dodge
a great branding without a phenomenal
product is also a dud of a company it's
that blend of both where you have
phenomenal branding and you have this
con and then wonderful product
um the example i always give is we you
know our seminal product at duluth
trading was what was called the long
tail t-shirt
it was the cure for plumber's butt right
and that really is what launched the
company
out of being a tool company into an
apparel company and honestly it was just
a tall t-shirt at the end of the day it
was a really wonderfully built you know
you know all the things you want in a
great t-shirt but it was just a little
longer
if you sold it as a tall t-shirt it
would have been a complete you know
miss but when you blend that with long
tail here for plumbers but we had an
amazing uh success
and that's the beauty of brand here
we're working really hard on creating a
brand
that is as good or better than our
product and we're doing a lot there so
that's the brand side
people
is you know as we say people's our
objective our third objective it's about
customer making sure that we are off the
charts when it comes to customer
experience and i will tell you and
everybody that will listen to this that
being a phenomenal customer experience
company is hard but it is a difficult
way to differentiate yourself most
companies are looking at ways
to uh idle back
cut costs
get you into that endless
spiral of hit one two three four
and our customers will tell you
that it's different
it's amazing it feels good i know that
what you promise you're going to deliver
on so customer experience can really be
a
driver but it's only a driver if you
measure it we use nps like most
companies do
and we we also i think the other thing
that we do here better than anywhere is
we take all of the data points that we
get we get customer reviews we get our
nps scores weekly we get our chat scores
we get our store
uh feedback and we blend it all into
this wonderful database weekly of what
are the custom what's
customer sentiment how are they feeling
and we relentlessly look at it and if it
falls we ask why and we look at reasons
why
um so that's the customer side
specifically
i've always been curious about you know
the strategies for measuring nps and for
being very intentional with with
understanding when they're when
something goes wrong and how to how to
fix it so so you're you're coming in and
one week you're saying ah you know the
last last week's score was not not as
great as we would like there are some
things we want to fix what do you do at
that point as as a leader here how do
you go and and figure out you know the
right way to fix you know your nps and
customer satisfaction overall
it's all about customer contact so in
the beginning when we launched nps a few
years ago um probably maybe three years
ago now
we didn't know what to do honestly we
just looked at a score and we looked at
are we competitive are we not
competitive with our our peers are we
competitive with the best in class um
customer experience oriented companies
and we said yeah we are we're really
good but we're not good enough so we set
a hundred basis point improvement every
year 100 basis point 100 basis point 100
basis point
and um so that's where we started and
now where we are is every week every
customer who gives us below a nine
gets a cop gets some form of contact
interesting a phone call from our
customer experience team an email and
it's a lot it's a ton but every possible
person that we can affect
we connect with and make sure it's a
better experience than where maybe we
left it with them and then we learned
from it and we had this thing in our
customer experience area in retail that
we call training tuesdays
so every week we learn from our monday
nps and our consolidation of all the
feedback and then our head of customer
experience
works it into the training tuesdays okay
so this individual had a an issue with
their prescription glasses we didn't do
a great job of measuring the seg height
whatever it is or the
the pd
how do we better train people to measure
the site height or the pd so it's it's
like this interesting ecosystem
interconnected and makes you know i
think a lot of companies look at the
results to your point but don't don't
know how to connect it to improvements
within the organization
and it takes time i will tell you i just
wrote a note to our board you know our
nps score improvements um are four years
in the making wow this isn't something
you flip a switch and see results it's
really it takes time so don't put too
much pressure as you implement you know
don't put too much pressure on yourself
to be a world-class company
immediately it does take time fantastic
so walk me through as you know as how
are you thinking strategically i'm going
into your website
and now transitioning to the direct to
consumer right and i'm going into the
website and
how do you think through strategically
the experience that i want to have so
you know how are you approaching me
and what are some different things that
you are doing within your platform that
are pushed or nudging me to get to that
mindset
yeah so i would tell you the first thing
to realize with eyewear is that it's 10
to 15 maybe 20 years behind other
clothing categories the percent of
eyewear specifically prescription that's
sold online is far lower than shoes and
shirts and pants and outerwear it just
is lagging
i think mainly because it's well how's
it going to look on me am i going to
look good or am i not going to look good
is it going to fit my head am i going to
be able to see
there's a lot of things related to a
really simple product right
so we start there we think what are the
barriers to trial for that new consumer
michael comes to our website and he
jumps on and he's the first time blue
light
glasses wearer
and he has no idea where to start so we
really have three things and i again it
gets back to customer focus we have
virtual try on
so we have a solution so that if you
want to see it real time with your
iphone
and you can see the glass many of our
glasses on your face
we have a style finder survey so we ask
you some fun questions about your style
your head size
how you're going to use them and then
output a much more limited group of
products we have over 400 style colors
so
narrowing it for for the customer's key
and then we have a virtual framing
session and a virtual framing session as
you go online you schedule a meeting
with one of our customer very capable
customer experience people
and they will walk you through the
process so look at your face michael
okay he looks like you're an average
now your head shape is this
i think let's try a few of these styles
then
most importantly we have a 90 day no
risk return policy so if for some reason
they just don't work
you can return or exchange them
and we also oftentimes have a customer
returns the product that's a negative
experience right so it's not it's it's a
negative i had to go through the effort
of returning this
not a great experience we'll go back to
them and say what was tell us what
happened
we you you know you you invested enough
time to buy a product from us how can we
help you find the right one
um and again that's just to me that's
closing the loop which a lot of a lot of
companies don't do in a in a one-to-one
way they're not going out and asking
that customer how do we make this right
how do we make it work
so
it's it's an understanding to answer
your question more simply it's a focused
understanding of what are the barriers
to trial
for that consumer either a prospect or
an or a
or an existing customer how do we help
them feel comfortable taking a risk with
a new brand or a brand that they know
and love
phenomenal phenomenal okay so we
understand some of the complexities
of d2c and building a brand that people
love understanding intentionality of you
know thinking through how to provide the
best experience for for the customers
you know whether it be through nps
course or through the to the personal
touches but now strategically growing
the company
how does a company like ibob said it's
set its vision
set its expectations towards the future
how do you measure you know healthy
growth
and and i'm coming more from the from
the software space and i'm sure i'm sure
that things are different but you know
what what do you consider is healthy
growth or healthy progression in this
day and age with ibom
but what did you know it could be a
product it can be a service it can be
software the the challenge for us all is
building awareness
still to this day i i'm sure michael you
didn't know that ibobs existed before we
were connected and that's our that's our
biggest challenge is creating awareness
we're not a huge company and creating
awareness with through big ad you know
10 million 50 million dollar uh
awareness building campaigns is not is
not our op it's not going to be the
solution for us it just isn't in the
cards we're a self-funded organization
we want to grow organically
so that just isn't the way we're going
to grow this business
i think there's a couple things first
you have to start where we started which
is building the foundation for
exceptional customer experience because
the best form of of
uh the best form maybe not the most
scalable form but the best form of
acquisition of customers is word of
mouth you know getting that customer to
say you gotta where'd you get those
glasses those are awesome well i bought
the best experience i've ever had buying
prescription eyewear and i got them
online online i can get prescription
eyewear online oh my gosh that's number
one so creating an amazing experience
with great products and great customer
experience getting that in place
secondly
i would say you know we're growing
through digital but i will tell you
there's an interesting thing happening
right now with a kind of a going back to
print
we do catalogs we do postcards
and we think that there's an opportunity
to introduce ourselves and our great
brand through
through print as well
and i'm i'm still very bullish on retail
um you know creating an uh there's no
better representation of our brand and
the store here at our corporate
headquarters or one of our other
two stores
and then you know having that customer
come in and be like oh my that's
different that's not like what i have
when i go to dr
smith
or you know
whatever other optical store that you go
to that just felt good
i'm gonna tell my friends about it so
the nice thing about
having physical brick and mortar at high
traffic locations is you just get a lot
of eyes on your your storefront you get
a lot of people coming in and just
checking it out
um and so i think for us it's going to
be a continued investment in digital
google facebook instagram
and
print so we still think print is a great
way to express our brands
and then uh retail but it's the blend of
all three that really will help us
capture and build our awareness
which is our number one challenge right
now
and i love it and obviously the world is
changing rapidly in terms of how how how
people become aware of things and and if
before it was mainly through the
the million dollar super bowl ad or
multi-million dollar super bowl ad of 20
years ago today there's obviously
different revenue streams there's
different avenues there's different
streams of you know of audiences and
where they where they get their
information from the various social
platforms
absolutely and i think the michael the
one thing i'll say in addition to that
is
you got to have believers within your
organization too i mean if we don't all
believe in this product that it'll
change people's lives that truly a great
pair of glasses can change your life
you're sunk and that's why we continue
to focus on employee engagement and
keeping people as the biggest advocates
for the brand that work here as we can
so i think you know it's just an
interesting odd combination some of the
things people never talk about but
you got to have you got to have
everybody in line
with the goals that are aligned with the
goals and excited about the product and
the business
if you don't have that it's going to be
really challenging
right and is there is it trivial to find
people that are that are excited about
your line of businesses and this is
obviously relevant for any d2c brand
is is it something that you
intentionally interview for and you and
you intentionally ask okay is my team
really excited about what i'm doing here
or is this another job for them
yeah yeah it's interesting yes we do um
we use a really wonderful
personality trait tool called culture
index
there's a ton of them out there but we
like culture index because
it really matches the if any job we have
has a profile that we create
and then a person who's a candidate will
take this personality profile takes 10
to 15 minutes and they'll line up with
that profile
and it's a critical that there's a and
we've proven it over time you know
everybody that's joined many people that
have joined us have been like oh this is
this sounds like black magic i don't
know i'm not sure but the reality of it
is it works it works because it forces
you to to create a great job description
create a profile and then
it also then helps you where there's
gaps
and asks questions in an interview to
say okay well why what this there's it's
just showing you as this kind of person
we need this kind of person tell me
about that and it's so yes we do
interview for it
um the cat we don't you know i would
tell you the majority of the people here
aren't from the eyewear industry
because we are we are
focusing on disrupting this industry we
have all it's a medical device we have
all of the technical expertise and we do
we're obviously 80 or
we're compliant with all of the
regulations
but i like bringing people into the
organization that bring a different
point of view maybe they've worked in
the outdoor industry
or they've worked in accessory
development or they've worked in retail
and in retail in um you know housewares
maybe
we have people that have very diverse
backgrounds and they bring different
things to us but as long as you have an
understanding of who you are as a brand
and you have the in our industry the
medical device
um understanding with technical
expertise there i love this kind of
melting pot of people with different
backgrounds and uh different
perspectives
i love it i love it and mike thank you
so so much for for the time and the
energy and and uh yeah i i love the
understanding of the complexity of the
agency but also about you know the
awareness strategy nps strategy and then
the differentiation
culminating and building the right
culture within the organization and
obviously 20 minutes is not enough to to
talk about you know
all about ibob and all the different
strategies but at least i felt like i
got a taste about the amazing the
amazing process and journey that you're
on and that i bob is on and and i
definitely learned a lot so thank you
very very much and stay safe and stay
healthy
you too michael thanks for the time have
a great day thank you very much